some time ago our office received an
email from a former marine named Zack
sabalos the email made its way around
the office folks were inspired they
cried when they read it and eventually I
got a copy of it and it did the same to
me I welled up as I read it I called
Zack to thank him for sending us a note
of such remarkable vulnerability and we
got to talking and I was so inspired by
him and his story and his journey that I
asked if I could meet him just by dumb
luck I found myself in Dallas which is
where Zack lives and we sat down to talk
his story is so compelling the reason to
share stories like this is because when
we hear people who sacrifice for others
when we hear stories of struggle and
overcoming that struggle it reminds us
that we too can be better versions of
ourselves and that true inspiration true
joy of life comes from doing things for
others here's the conversation I had
with Zack
it's such an honor
music I'm happy to be here can you tell
me your story again
tell me the story that you wrote to me
in the email in 2011 we deployed to
saying in Afghanistan
singing nowadays has been considered you
know the Fallujah of Afghanistan it was
the bloodiest warfare war or bloodiest
battle excuse me since Fallujah and so
at that time we lost 17 Marines out of
how many we lost 7k Marines I have a
little under a thousand we also had 191
severely wounded and it was you know the
wound the guys with the wounds or
anything from single gunshot wound to
believe a triple amputee I was fortunate
to uh to come home you know you know in
the condition I did and by the time
there with the 17 Marines that we lost
there's two individuals that were key to
me one of them was my saw gunner who's a
squad automatic weapon light machine
gunner basically and so he was hit by an
IED II he became a triple amputee and
passed away isn't aeneas Lee the other
marine that really struck me was my um
my roommate you know just like in
college you have your roommate do
everything's with each other
party together hang out study whatever
at the time I was like okay you know
what it didn't hit me yet no it was so
surreal so just mind-blowing that my
best friend my roommate was gone you
know we did everything together when we
we did our field days on Thursdays and
Marine Corps he listens to say music
over and over and over and it just drew
me up a wall I hated the music you
listen to he wasn't 60 wasn't 63 he was
six two and a half the size 12 view and
I knew anything about this green eyes he
was you know of Irish heritage everybody
loved him and so June 12 2011 he was hit
by a rocket in a vehicle and so when I
got to him he was already in his body
back the helicopter came landed the crew
chief popped out and he saluted the way
you're supposed to slide him in is the
first to put him on top of the
helicopter and then move side and second
to you you're slightly up the person I
didn't do that I just kind of slid you
know did slow motion and their guys like
what he don't know it's not where we
trained for
and I couldn't let go of his boot you
know it was like tall boots so he could
definitely see it in the back and then
the crew chief he's just like you gotta
let go you gotta look out we gotta go
you gotta let go and I'm thinking like
is this guy talking you know emotionally
is he talking or physically and I just
looked at him and they they just saw you
know tears coming down my face and he
put up his eye protection and he's like
I know I know and I just I grabbed him
by his body armor and I just was shaking
I couldn't I don't know what to do and
then and then so I just all I could say
was you know like make sure he gets home
to this day I still had that dream know
that day and then um we finish the rest
of deployment at that point you know
ultimately we suffered you know 17
Marines passing away and so I left the
Marine Corps in 2012 prior to leaving
stuff started happening to me mentally
emotionally I didn't know how did what
it was I didn't know how to deal with it
and so ultimately you know I tried
suicide four times so the first time if
I had a bad dream and it was the first
time I had that dream the very first
time and it was too real I panicked I
was bawling a head off and put my helmet
on and I just went on my motorcycle and
so I tried ran my my motorcycle into you
know the trucks several times and for
whatever reason that truck would always
didn't know is there and just would
change the lane as soon as I hit it I
was going well over 160 miles so this is
just some clear you're driving 160 miles
an hour your plan is to ram your
motorcycle into the back of a truck and
just as it's about to happen the truck
changes lanes exactly yeah it was on the
California on the 5 yeah and I was
miserable now I was getting so upset
because this guy was not allow me to be
at peace seem sense and so a little
while later same dreams same nightmares
panicked and then I got my motorcycle
and I tried ramming into when those
cement pillars that holds up bridges
I hit a bump hit a curb or something my
rear tire hit a patch of dirt or gravel
and it slid and it just my bike pushed
me off and pushed me into the dirt and I
was like and I stopped and I was just
like what's the deal you know I was like
I'm trying to do this what's the deal
you know what's going on my third
attempt was going to oncoming traffic
and I did it and I was going there going
about 45 50 or so I was going I was
going about 60 or so I just member cars
it's like honking and going around me
honking and going around me and I was
weaving my motorcycle and uh yeah in it
I was beat I was just like what's going
on I'm trying to do what I'm trying to
do him try and do it and I couldn't do
it like it it wasn't me it was something
else mother for something whatever so I
didn't know what to do um my last time
was jumping off a bridge in California
I'd rather not talk about that
experience yeah and so tried four times
I didn't know what was going on at
having those dreams about what happens
in Afghanistan I was nightmares and
stuff and it was just so intense and I
didn't realize at the time I didn't
realize that hey you're gonna be you
know what happened here you know you
want to mean a person blow up you know
you're not going to think about it right
now but you know in a year later from
now you're gonna remember this in your
dreams never thought it would that would
happen to me
and so for a couple of years about two
and a half years I really suffered I
just blocked everybody off there was
times it come in waves and when I would
come in waves it would last you know
sometimes a few days or it lasts almost
a couple of months I'd be depressed I
wouldn't care like whatever I wouldn't
shave I stopped eating I would just I'm
done and the biggest thing was like you
know I'd felt very undeserving like you
know why should I get this when my buddy
didn't come home everything that I did
related to my time in Afghanistan I was
diagnosed at that point with
posttraumatic stress and that's when the
VA is like here's a paperwork this is
what it is it's going on
have approved that you know you have
post MEK stress and that was a culture
shock thing to me it was like I can't
have it I can't have it I deployed it
one time I was like there's other guys
deployed six seven times or more and
those are the guys it wasn't so much
embarrassment but failing of undeserving
right to have that diagnosed exactly and
you know at a one time deployment the
biggest thing is especially for marine
was they felt weak and to be diagnosed
with that it was a sign of weakness it
was like you're weak these other guys
are strong but you're weak you're
singled out you're by yourself you're
weak and I was like I can't have that
I can't be I can't you know come off as
a weak I don't want to do it and then
the VA says yeah you do have post next
dress and then I was like I'm weak you
know that's it I'm weak I'm just
everything negative that's possible
that's me you know I'm a loser I'm weak
I don't deserve the title the Marine
Corps marine and I deserve to have
served with Marines I served with I
don't deserve anything I don't deserve
to be here don't deserve to be alive
because not only the 17 my brothers
don't come home but two of my more
closest brothers not come home and so it
really affected me and so that was I
believe October 2014
another thing that happened was I met a
very important person in my life now and
he founded this organization gallant
view and I was at a slump and this is
right around Thanksgiving time I met him
and he took me out to dinner his wife
took me out to dinner and I was like I
don't know anything about this guy is
like he just buy me a nice dinner I was
just like okay cool and so the worst
thing is I'm getting a free dinner at
this and so but then he just sat there
and listened and then I just found
myself for the first time in years
just like what we call him rink or data
dump you know just tell him everything
he's just sitting down just listening
and eating and I knew he was a veteran
as well but that's all I really knew
about him and then he just sat there and
listened and then instantaneously there
was you know a bond that was forged
there you know it took a little while to
progress and become what it is today but
that was you know planting the seed and
so you know I signed up on the website
and then he was kinda like hey you know
come rock climb and come to you there's
coming you know come hang out and let's
you know do better in things together
and I was a guy right so I tried a rock
climbing
we went on a retreat in Colorado with
Raider Project sister organization of
dalip you and the guys that were kind of
leading in and someone in charge but
were Marines they weren't you know
doctors they weren't physicians they
weren't you know pas or anything like
that they're just guys like me who've
had you know a little bit more of
extensive backgrounds and now it's
thinking you know this is awesome I was
like then the one thing that when the
guys says you don't need to act tough
you are tough you've proven yourself and
that's something I still take to heart
to this today today and so I realized
like well these guys are taking a care
of each other you know that Brotherhood
that camaraderie is still alive that I
knew in the Marine Corps I was like
these guys don't know I don't know any
of them but yet they're looking out for
me and so I was ecstatic and so I got
back and then I was like I want to do
something I want to I want to like I
wouldn't do something with veterans
though I mean just do something a day of
hanging out with veterans or something
because I realized at that point I was
like I need get plugged into something
that people are like me and veterans
were like me either combat or none
whatever I want to be in that
brotherhood again and I realized at that
point this is what I need and and so it
went from a small idea I like getting
veterans to get together to go let's go
to the gun range just hang out and go to
get some food
it went from that idea to a full-blown
pheasant hunt it was more than just a
pheasant hunt I was like this come here
and let's learn about some you know
emotional psychological healing because
there's are a lot of guys out there who
didn't know anything about that the day
after we got back one of the Marines
texted me and he said you said thanks
for allowing me to come with you is like
my girlfriend can really tell a
difference in me he's like thank you I
needed that and so when I got that I was
like man this is awesome like no me
Dunas you know I possibly could saving
you know a dad brother you know sister
mom you know a family ultimately and by
me doing this I can be helping reduce
the veteran suicide rate and I love it
because you know I'm tired of losing my
brothers and sisters you know these
thing people have done you know these
astronomical you know feats in combat or
in non-combat and they're not recognized
for it which I can understand but the
same time and it's thinking there's no
reason for you be taking her own life
and
you know and it hurts me the fact that
you know they do this you lost 17 guys
and come back yes how many guys have you
lost post comeback since I have another
Marine Corps from my actual unit I've
lost six Marines
you've lost six Marines from unit in
addition to the 17s assists six to
suicide yes I think a lot of people also
I don't real I don't realize that
there's very few combat suicides like
very few servicemen and servicewomen
kill themselves in combat it's post
combat right it's when they've come home
and more often than not it's very often
when they've retired when they're out of
the service
definitely the horror of war the that
you've seen and been around horrible
things and yet there's a warmth that
combat vets have to being in combat
there's a there's a they almost miss it
they didn't miss the hell yeah but they
miss something can you talk about that
do you have that yeah definitely and
because you tell this in the story of
intensity that that set you on a path of
destruction and yet you have a warmth
towards your time
downrange time can you talk about what
that warmth is with that with what you
miss it's knowing that I love my guide
to the left and right at me or behind me
in front of me and I'm gonna do whatever
I can to my and all of my being to make
sure he goes home to his family why
because he would do it for me you know
my my squad leader my team leader
whatever they would do it for me they're
gonna take care of me so I'm gonna take
care of them a lot of veterans that I've
talked to you miss it because of the
people they served with because they
understand what it is to not be related
somebody by blood but to share blood
with them to spill their own blood and
to realize that this is my brother this
is my sister in the private sector we
work with colleagues and co-workers and
in the military you have brothers and
your sisters it's a very different you
know and there's an intensity of love
that and support and trust and the
willingness to serve not God in country
but each other and the absolute
confidence you have that someone is
there to help keep you alive and take
care of you all so that when you retire
when you separate you lose that it's
nobody wants to go back to the horrors
of war but you miss and love the
camaraderie and the love and the in the
community and can you talk a little bit
about sort of how is it that that sets
you on the spiral that you know you feel
alone that I feel I feel like the
biggest thing is when you you have your
purpose in the Marine Corps I don't care
if you're an admin if you're an officer
if you're a cook if you're whatever a
grunt special forces you know marine
counting I don't care what it is you
know your purpose you wake up and you
know your job and then all sudden you
get your discharge paperwork and the
Marine Corps spy you're on your own now
the biggest thing that hits is the
isolation factor once the isolation
factor hits things like I'm by myself I
don't have my squad leader to report to
you and all my team leaders I don't have
my platoon commanders my platoon
sergeants I don't have any any of these
people and so that's when you know a
variety of negative things start
happening well you know I'm having these
dreams I can't talk to him about it I
can't relate to anybody about it my guys
are I was with an Afghanistan Iraq or
Syria now you know whoever I was with
they're deployed again I can't talk to
any of them and that's when you know the
biggest thing isolation factor substance
abuse comes in you go through so much so
many experiences over there in just a
short amount of time you know a there's
a fraction of your life that you are
gonna be deployed to the Middle East in
our case we are there 7-7 half months in
such a small time but yet our lives have
changed dramatically and so intensely
and the fact is that the military you're
there take care of each other
you know it's a team effort team effort
King job tell me what gallant few does
that that replaces that feeling so
gallant few is great because it's a
support network it is it helps find you
know veterans in your local area that
you can partner with because we've
realized that the one of the most
significant things is isolation factor
when you're out of the military and you
hit the isolation factor you're like I'm
by myself well I'm gonna no self
medicate but we're like hey well before
you do that before you die before you
die check this guy up he did the same
job you did about 20 years ago but he's
now a doctor in
st. Louis what you know or right where
you're at we want you to link up with
him and then you know y'all can work a
job out together and y'all you know
working with each other and help each
other out that's how we overcome the
isolation factor that's how we defeat a
veteran feeling alone and hopefully
preventing other things from happening
though you connect with your platoon
through social media and through a chat
group and technology you already have
the bond with them they are your platoon
that's they they are your friends
already but but what's so important is
that your organization that you're part
of that Karl monger started gallant few
its local there's real human connections
it's not some email chatroom thing you
know it's not a Facebook group for
veterans it's human beings going rock
climbing it's human beings going hunting
it's human beings going out for dinner
it's human beings sitting down with each
other's human beings talking and telling
stories it's crying it's laughing it's
real and human and and again in the
military is exaggerated in the sense of
feelings but I want everybody to
understand the importance of the hard
work it takes to be a part of a
community and serve the community so let
me ask you a difficult question was it
worth it yeah it's a painful question
it's painful answer but to know what I
have now it's it's unfathomable to
explain its I have I have a family I
have my brothers I have a purpose in
life and yes I we had to go through hell
and back to get it some of us still
struggle but the fact is just like how
we took care of it took care of each
other in Afghanistan we're taking care
of each other here hey he's struggling
pick him up let's go you know we're not
leaving him behind I'm not gonna say hey
good luck with your addiction nope
we're gonna all fly to him talk to him
we're here for each other let's talk a
little bit about purpose one of the
things the mist of the mistakes that
people make is they think purpose comes
from their job right and we see this in
military and non-military which is I've
been
whatever for so many years and when then
I lose my job or I retire I now don't
have a sense of purpose because I've so
closely associated my self-worth with
the job that I did and you said that
happened even in the military where I
knew what my job was I had a sense of
purpose and one wonders if those things
are conflated right which is I had a
sense of purpose for my job and then
when I didn't have the job when I left
the military all of all of a sudden I
sense I didn't know what I woke up in
the morning didn't know what to do you
had a sense of service because of the
community and now you've found a sense
of service because you're literally in
service to you to that community again
but it's not the job it's the sense of
service I don't even consider this a job
or a career you know I consider my
passion I'm like I will keep on doing
this you don't give your money I love
doing this and it's funny on my previous
jobs I get in trouble like hey you're
taking too much time off like I don't
care I need to do these I need hang out
these guys I need to take care of them I
need to I need to do and I love it and I
this this is it for me that I've I'm
fortunate and lucky enough to find my
purpose in yeah and I'm gonna keep it
and the purpose in life is and this is
what I want to stress to any vet who's
listening to those are watching this
which is the purpose is not your MOS or
your purpose is not your ass all gunner
your purpose is not the job that you
wake up to do every day your purpose is
something bigger and in your case your
purpose is to show up to the group not
even knowing what you're getting into
simply showing up there and being open
to the fact that somebody you might know
we might need you that's it and to get
other people to show up and you have
been your happiest and most fulfilled at
the times in your life when you did that
can you tell people who may be
interested in either giving to gallant
few or being a part of yellow few if
they're veterans how they can get ahold
you guys so we are on all social media
you know Facebook Instagram things of
that nature we're on we're on it they
can send us a message by the same time
we also have websites gallon PU org and
it's basically a way to get a hold of us
all I got to do is better and sign up
his contact information
submit you know dd-214 or ID card and
that's it and then I'll call you I'll
talk to them and then we'll see what's
going on and a lot of times veterans
like you know I just want to help I want
to help and like a great
well there's you know a little pocket of
veterans in your community you'll go
link up with them and let's you know
I'll give you a task you know maybe go
have breakfast on Saturday morning just
go get some coffee
have you know relax and hang out and
then that's it
but by doing this by reaching out to all
these individuals who want to help and
who need help or requesting help it's
doing nothing but proven to me that that
Brotherhood in the camaraderie yeah is
the life and well we're proving it we're
showing that it's happening we're here
to take care of each other you're not
gonna get far in life if you don't take
care each other and I love I love the
fact that I was able to find this
organization I love the fact I maybe
will still talk to my Marines talk talk
trash shut down and say I love you and
I'm gonna back you up and I'm gonna see
you in a couple of weeks I love it
and that's that's it my purpose that's
my purpose to be here is to show up as
you say I have learned more about what
it means to be human
civilian what are you want to call it
from the military than from anybody else
who doesn't we're in a uniform which is
I understand and I learned a long time
ago which is my own sense of camaraderie
and Brotherhood and sisterhood and
community is the thing that helps me
stay inspired is the thing that saves me
when I'm in the dark place is the thing
that motivates me and and it's hard in
this modern day and age to find an
intense sense of community or love in in
the general population and I think
technology makes it even more difficult
you know because we were connected but
we're not connecting and when I started
hearing stories from people that I met
in the military about Brotherhood and
sister and again
we called each other brothers you know I
wanted to learn quite frankly because my
complaint was why can't I have that
you know why can't we all have that why
can't everybody have that and and you
you said it which is the it's not that
the Marine Corps or the military is
different it's that the because the
stakes are life and death everything's
exaggerated
right and so the reason I reached out to
you to thank you first of all for
sending the email the courage to send
the email quite frankly I mean you send
you're sending a very personal email to
basically a total stranger
who's who cannot relate to your
experience because I you know I haven't
done what you've done I I learn I close
attention to the language you use and
the the the truth is I wanted to put I
wanted to do this on camera I wanted to
talk to you on camera in for two reasons
one because you and I both shared the
desire to for other veterans who may see
this so that they understand that there
that there are others like them who
shared their experiences that they're
they're not by themselves but rather
they're a part of a community still and
whether it's gallant view or another
organization that there are people in
their community who they can call up and
say can I talk I'm struggling I I hope
that this saves a few lives you know
just just long enough that someone can
make a phone call to somebody who would
take care of them exactly and also to
people who aren't veterans to try and
learn more about the importance of real
human bonds I so appreciate you taking
the time I appreciate an honor to meet
you thank you thank you so much thank
you if you want to give two gallon for
you go to gallon few org if you're
veteran who's looking for that sense of
community again or to give others that
sense of community please visit their
website and reach out to them on all
social media and a true honor thank you
thank you